hey you guys it's movie review in time
and we are taking advantage of our new
shutter subscription yeah turn it up
yeah oh my god they have so many good
movies and because it's October they're
adding a bunch of a bunch of classics so
we're gonna have a really lot of movies
to do that have been on my list and I'm
so happy that so many of them are on
there I mean [ __ ] they got like the
original Halloween they got Cannibal
Holocaust
what spell probably do a Tara night
tearing up shudder we've been tearing up
studs stubs a list from AMC Theatres
Stern a-list does well when you're using
it it's three movies a week damn well
yeah we're taking her advantage
we're actually gonna go we're recording
this on Thursday and we're gonna go see
our third one saw the predator last yes
it was okay okay wasn't as bad as I
thought was gonna be and we saw the meg
and today we're gonna go see the nun
yeah yeah they're really on their way
out all three of those and then tomorrow
we're getting uh tomorrow I took Friday
morning at resets zero after tomorrow we
have three more so we'll see yeah we are
gonna see I want to see Mission
Impossible before that goes to yeah
there was another one I think we wanted
to see but we'll see how that goes
but anyway today we're talking about a
bonafide
horror classic re-animator yeah 1985 now
we did a review of beyond reanimate er
the third in the series and we'll
probably eventually get around to doing
bride of re-animator but I was like you
know we really really have to do because
how do not do reanimate her I mean this
game should have seen this one you need
to be slapped pretty much yeah I'm just
really free animator this is kind of one
of those movies like Creepshow where if
you if you don't like this movie then we
can't be friends yes I'm sorry
is it yeah it's just how can you not
love reanimate urge every calls a young
like this is like the [ __ ] easily
easily one of the best horror a woman
literally getting head yes yeah getting
head from a head looking ridiculous its
HP Lovecraft based story loosely based
on something yeah fairly
yes yes um he just kind of mentioned
about a guy who was a scholar who
learned how to bring people back to life
with some kind of serum like you do and
then the trouble that would all cause
well the story behind this one obviously
directed by Stuart Gordon this was
actually his first theatrical feature
prior to that he had actually been
involved with a theatre group so he did
a lot of stage plays and things like
that yeah you know it was kind of like
it wasn't like Broadway or anything like
that but it was kind of like
transgressive sort of theater and he was
talking to some friends one night so the
story goes and he's like you know
there's too many [ __ ] Dracula movies
in too many vampire movies why didn't he
make Frankenstein type movies anymore
yeah and some one of his other friends
who knew he was a big Lovecraft fan
I said well have you ever read Lovecraft
serial that came out in 1922 it came out
in pieces you know called Herbert West
re-animator and it was out of print at
that point but Stewart Gordon was like
oh no I haven't read that one so maybe
he's like well if you're in the
Frankenstein go read that [ __ ] so he
went to the library and read it and he's
like okay we need to make something out
of this now the first iteration of this
he was actually going to make it like a
stage play and then he was talking to
the other writers Denis Paoli and the
other guy Cameron Bure his name right
now but they're like well maybe we
should make it into a TV series because
like I said it was a serial so they
actually wrote a script for a pilot and
they said we think it's gonna be half an
hour and then maybe an hour and then
we're gonna do like 12 or 13 episodes so
then he's talking to somebody else and
they're like you know it horror doesn't
really work on TV you need to make this
into a movie
so he's like come out to Hollywood I'll
get you a producer you know hey
introducing her Brian Jasna and he's
like okay well we'll make this into a
movie so they start working on this
movie it costs less than a million
dollars to make this was in 1985 right
and I I feel like the best thing about
well other than I mean everything
everything is good about this movie I
just there are no complaints about this
movie like I said it's just like I was
saying about creeps yeah you have to
understand the movie had to take his
movie in the context of the time - yeah
I mean there's
complaints when you put into context of
the time it's um it's it's a milestone
flick and matter-of-fact to get a really
good copy of this on blu-ray it's sort
of like steelbook editions you know they
have people paying fifty sixty dollars
to get like a good copy of this you know
all the little steelbook conditions this
is a classic movie you know it's just a
great movie I think the thing that makes
this really work yeah is that one you
can tell that it was made with a great
deal of care and a great deal of
affection yeah but it also in in a weird
kind of way
it doesn't take itself too seriously yet
all the actors are playing it completely
straight yeah and I think that makes it
really work I mean particularly Jeffrey
Combs this was his star-making turn I
mean this yeah if this was the only
movie he had ever done you'd still
remember you would still remain it would
still be like a cults you know icon when
we first saw him you know cuz I selves
when it came out me and my buddies you
know we could only get it like on VHS at
that time we were blown away by this guy
who is this guy yeah it was that dude
you know we just loved the guy and then
went front when from beyond came out
later you know we were all on board with
that - yeah which that's another great
milestone yeah we're gonna have to do
that would do that one occasionally but
uh yeah and actually the speaking of
Stuart Stuart Gordon shudder also has
Castle freak so we're definitely gonna
have to do that when it's wrong so I
haven't seen that in a long time but the
thing like the cool thing about Jeffrey
Combs and I think the reason why this
sort of made him a cult icon as I said
was because one he takes the role
completely seriously
yeah his intensity he's yeah he's like
this little guy and he's very young in
this I had forgotten yeah but he is like
he's kind of really intensely scary and
stuff and he's he's kind of like an
[ __ ] but he's still kind of lovable
in a weird way and I think it's because
the way he comes across it's like he
comes across as like a know-it-all and
he's very intelligent but you can tell
that he has the smarts to back that up
he's not just some guy that's like going
around going I'm smarter than everybody
he really is smarter than everybody and
he's also a psycho yeah you know but you
know he's on a quest to conquer death
yeah yeah and in a way it's like I think
you can kind of relate to his like
passion about the subject even though he
does is some intensely intensely [ __ ]
up things in this movie it's like you
can understand that he's like he's the
smartest guy in the world he's figured
out how to bring people back from the
dead and you know so and he's just like
so into this quest that he just doesn't
care who gets in his way or anything
like that but he's still like I said
he's kind of likable even though he's
totally weird and honest but he's kind
of rationalized himself out of having
any kind of aversion to death yeah cuz
death and life are just two different
stasis is that he can change killing
somebody out no big deal I can I can
just bring him back bring it back that's
actually a good way of putting it
he conquered he'd conquered what he
conquered death in his own mind he
didn't have a an aversion to it yeah
yeah so what we get now I should note
too that when this movie first came out
I believe it first premiered they
premiered it at the Cannes Film Festival
in France and they loved that [ __ ] over
there there it got a special prize and
everything like that they're like the
audience's were just going apeshit over
it they just love it so then when they
released it in the theatres it actually
ended up making a lot of money initially
they wanted to make all these cuts to
get an R rating because it was gonna get
an X rating before cuz it's pretty gory
and it's got some weird sex upsetting
sexual yeah even for today I think
people would probably be like I don't
think they make this movie today I don't
I mean there's too many people I know
well I don't know about that because
I've seen some recent ones that had some
pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's true that
cuz we were talking about independent
films oh yeah Hollywood studio would
never make this movie well no but they
wouldn't have made it back they wouldn't
made it back then now okay so like I
said all the other horrific [ __ ] there
were is movies most of them were
particularly the 80s were all in like
independently yeah but um there's the
ones that really had pulled all the
weight with my generation yeah well
those are the ones that are so long
about regeneration in general yeah but
the thing is about this it's like so the
cuts that they wanted to make to make
this an R movie had they made all the
cuts that they wanted the movie would
have ended up being 40 minutes long
nothing was acceptable which yet so now
there are there so there were a couple
of cuts floating around of this because
there was kind of an r-rated version
that they would show on cable or that
they were show on TV on some video
stores that didn't want to show like
unrated movies you know they had a
version for them now there was a lot of
other stuff filmed for it and put back
into it that was you know to make it
long to make it feature-length some of
that stuff had to do with there was a
subplot about dr. hill the guy that gets
beheaded how he was like hypnotizing all
his victims they yeah they just kind of
touch down in the movie they didn't rly
but there was a whole subplot about that
there was a little subplot about Jeffrey
Combs doctor West taking some of the
serum himself like to keep him awake it
was like you know kind of a pep filled
type of thing there was a little bit
about that but as far as I know you can
either see the super gory unrated
version or the version that has all the
other subplots in it
I think Germany is the only country that
is done like a supercut that has all the
gore and the sex and all the subplots in
it as well yeah the ones that people pay
big money for yeah yeah so that's my new
book editions we have books in them and
there are a lot of extras I'm almost
tempted to kind of splurge and buy
something like that you know really we
should because I have to say it's like I
saw re-animator many years ago probably
the same time you did it was Lady these
problem into late eighties yeah when it
came out on video I did see the Unrated
version so you know yeah and I actually
hadn't seen it since then I don't think
I might have seen it once in the 90s but
when it came up on shutter like oh we
got to do that one because we already
did be Andre animator and I remember
loving this movie and we sat and watched
it with a couple drinks like we usually
do yeah and I had forgotten it's like I
remembered loving this movie but I'd
forgotten how [ __ ] awesome
and balls out and saying it yeah and
it's wonderful it's it wonderful the
weird kind of tone to it almost comedy
but really dark comedy in a way you know
I had a lot of comedic parts and
everything which it yeah which I love I
love that [ __ ] and what was lighters
I was kind of seeing a a weird
parallel between another unlikely
candidate that I was comparing this to
those frighteners frighteners kind of
had that weird comedic quality but this
one had that same quality the difference
was is that frighteners was definitely
there was not a strong R rating it was
you know I mean frighteners was not
gross yeah you know wasn't horrible
didn't have a horror element to it even
though I loved frighteners it kind of
had that weird funny tone to it though
it's interesting because one other
person on IMDB because I was reading
some other reviews of it earlier today
one other person said that too really
that it was kind of like it that it was
that same kind of vibe and obviously
Jeffrey Combs was also yeah we did add
some dude to edit something do it the
humor yeah
actually I think Jeffrey Combs was in it
oh yeah which is different it was also
in the frighteners right but um I think
this is funnier than the frighteners um
in that weird twisted way you know weird
well that's my sense of humor you know I
I mean I think this movie is hilarious
so it's like I can I can see if you're
not into gore and you're not into like
super morbid humor then you might not
think it's funny but I think it's
hysterical it's really it's one of the
funniest if not the funniest horror
comedy I mean it's like right up there
with Evil Dead um in terms of just sheer
insanity it has such a great energy to
it it's really it's really fast paced
it's like it's there's no slow parts
nothing boring happens it's like every
single scene goes 1 scene 1 scene 1
scene it's just a more crazy [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and it's just crazy [ __ ]
happening through the whole entire thing
another thing for any of our younger
viewers is that this movie was a
milestone in the context of the time
it's as if horror movies were slowly
building up to this and then finally it
arrived at this laughs oh wow yeah this
is a contemporary horror movie I
remember that you know we were thinking
that this was the ultimate
accomplishment in horror at the time
that it came out and it kind of had a
natural
I you know you know like a you could
feel that natural progression in the
movies at the time it was just you know
guess you just had had to be there and
then when from beyond came came out in a
way it kind of crowned this one that's
how we yeah we liked them both you know
they were both different but from Bria
from beyond had that weird sexual
element yeah to it yeah I mean that we
that really stood out it was it was a
good time for horror it really was I
mean the early eighties there was a lot
of good stuff I mean the 70s is probably
still you know just in terms of classic
horror films is probably still number
one in the early 80s I feel like there
was a lot of good movies that came out
but there was like a lot of like slasher
like derivative slasher type movies too
especially like you know Halloween
ripoffs and stuff but this was really
something original you know how I
remembered it being different
it was fast-paced for once and ya didn't
have the slow pace of the 70s once it
actually showed you everything it was
talking about unlike 70s it had a weird
sense of humor to it and there was a big
science fiction element to the horror
yeah that you know they were trying to
make it scientifically kind of plausible
or at least you know well didn't
scientist yes as an excuse for showing
like I said it was a Frankenstein yeah
so the odd was in that same thing when
they were using the resonator yeah yeah
I mean so it was kind of cool it was
just like a new era of these new horror
movies that were coming and with you
were a kid in those days it was just
blowing you away yeah I mean I have to
say that even though Jeffrey Combs like
steals the show obviously I really like
a lot of the other actors in this the
guy that plays his roommate who kind of
gets worked into helping him I like that
that guy he's sort of like a straight
arrow type character I mean he's
well-meaning but he just kind of gets
sucked into this and so he plays a good
foil
I think against Herbert West character
also Barbara Crampton obviously she's
like so good in this yeah and she's just
really believable she's great screamer
you know everybody get to see her boobs
you know if you're into that you're
gonna see more than that well yeah you
could see pretty much all over we're
Crampton yeah like I said there's some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on this and kids if
you see this you have to see the Unrated
version because the r-rated version has
the most famous scene which probably the
most one of the most famous scenes in
all of horror history taken out yeah
because I mean not only is it you know
the head scene yeah but also her
zombified dad yes right this like
helping out yeah but and also the gore
in this I mean it's it's 80s gore it's
all practical yeah it's not to dilute
it's not believable but it is a policy
yeah the thing about this movie is that
they knew that the premise was
ridiculous they knew it was just it's
kind of like in the same vein to is like
you know if you're gonna go you know
around the globe we're gonna go to
Australia and do like Dead Alive like
the Peter Jackson movie where he's just
okay well I'm just gonna make the most
over-the-top crazy is like [ __ ] Gore
fest I can ever he just goes for it yeah
and I kind of like that this movie has
the courage of its convictions it's like
we're just gonna make this over the top
and we're gonna roll with exploitation
movie we're gonna like the actors are
gonna play it straight like this is
really happening
but we're kind of like acknowledging how
crazy this is but not in a winking
ironic kind of way which is why I didn't
like a lot of 90s horror movies they
were like look out like I didn't like
that kind of winking ironic attitude and
this really does not have that it is
very earnest and it comes across so it
comes across very good like I said
Jeffrey Combs is like this sort of
deadpan like his [ __ ] deadpan humor
like with the like the whole thing with
the cat yeah and like he's sitting there
going what you know what was I supposed
to do leave a note that says dead cat
details later you know a deadpan
although you're talking about how
implausible it is I can remember at the
time being a teenage boy thinking oh
yeah this could totally happen yeah man
my god that [ __ ] that's how it's
supposed to happen
it's supposed to happen that will happen
eventually
they come back to life and even the
parts I really like to that I mean you
can tell they they took a lot of care
with the gore Stewart Gordon and the guy
that was working on the effects it's
like we got all these books from you
know that's like anatomy books within
you know pathology books that had like
pictures of corpses and stuff because
they wanted to get like the lividity
right so like a lot of the corpses that
are getting up walking around it's like
you'll note that they have like
particular patterns of kind of gore on
them or like where the blood pooled and
stuff so they actually like really you
know they really kind of went a long way
toward they wanted it to look as
realistic as possible
oh I bet this this is something you'll
find interesting that I bet you didn't
know you know the the kind of muscle
guide like the first guy that Herbert
West and dr. K reunited yeah yeah that
they reanimate the big guy yeah it was
that was actually Arnold Schwarzenegger
is body double okay on several movies
yeah yeah so you can see how yeah so
like I said I don't think we're you know
we've gotten this far we haven't even
really talked about the plot but it's a
it's kind of just like you know it's a
mad scientist-type story essentially
it's Jeff yeah it's dr. West he's he was
in Switzerland and we're led to believe
that maybe he was kicked out of medical
school for his experiments he ends up
back in the United States at Miskatonic
University he kind of inserts himself
into the you know I like how he just
shows up at his roommates house and he's
like oh I'm moving in heard you had a
room for rent yeah nice basement I'm
staying I think he actually it goes to
class well no he did go to class cuz he
broke my pencil during this yeah he did
go to class with you know with dr. Hill
and he was talking about how and I mean
the whole thing with with dr. hill that
whole subplot you know with him good
[ __ ] oh she's trying to get in there she
thinks that's a door out yeah it's
closet well she comes in and she
scratches at the closet door and then
she's like Pete Pete Pete yeah I'm like
okay but that's not outside I tell you
every time and I open the doors and then
she looks at me like yeah look she there
she is
she does this like almost every day it's
not outside its the closet pookie you
can go in there and play if you want to
but it's not outside she's looking at us
like why isn't it outside yeah they make
it outside blaming me for bad weather
yeah it's hot and she looks at me like
it's hot that's all she and her little
bat goes up like oh no I don't like this
fix it yeah it's goddamn she's adorable
yeah she's like our kids that's what
that's what we call her yeah but yeah so
the whole part the whole thing with with
dr. hill and him kind of having the
whole lecherous thing about the Dean's
daughter and there's that whole creepy
[ __ ] and then he's all like [ __ ] he
doesn't like dr. West and dr. West
doesn't like him and then the horrible
[ __ ] that happens like at the end I
think that's like kind of the book the
best thing about this movie but like I
said people that have-not if you haven't
seen reanimate ER what like I said what
the [ __ ] are you even doing here
yeah this is easily easily one of the
best movie of the 80s just like I said
about Creepshow easily one of the best
horror comedies ever made yeah and the
great thing about its low budget yeah
like I said yeah less than a million
dollars and it actually ended up making
a couple million dollars profit when it
was in the theater and then obviously it
went on to become a cult classic so yeah
it's still making money so it's probably
still is because like I said you know
you get new generations of horror fans
coming up all the time and going back
and watching all the classics and I
think this is one that even though it's
from the 80s I think it still holds up
like I said you know it's hard for me to
say cuz I'm old but they were used to
those motifs and use those backgrounds
to me it didn't really feel that old it
really didn't it doesn't seem like it's
all that dated or all that you know
has the speed at which it unravels or
unfolds I mean it's a yes pace story
it's really it's a yeah it's only an
hour and 25 minutes yeah and there's
nothing boring about it and that was
really what we noticed first back in the
80s and this came out is about how
fast-paced it was it was almost like
action-adventure yeah almost kinda like
watching terminator 1 or predator it was
just constant it's all the stories
rolling there's nothing no dead spots
and yeah it just it just constantly
stays in motion no time II need from the
opening scene yeah and that is from one
thing to another when your kid were not
overly analyzing it there wasn't any
classic action scenes you know with
buses flipping and [ __ ] like that but it
seemed like there was action in it yeah
you know corpses fight and trying to get
in and look at it now it's not really
you know if you really try to analyze
you go this isn't an action movie but it
does have action in it there's a lot of
corpse fights there's you know there's
of there's beheadings there's all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah it makes you
think more you think Morris more happens
in it that actually happens but yeah
yeah a lot happens that's because it's a
good script yeah
and I was gonna say too another thing
when I was talking about Jeffrey Combs
being in this and his kind of deadpan
humor one of my other favorite things is
when he just totally very calmly when
this corpse is going apeshit when he
just very calmly picks up a bone saw and
he's just like honey just like there's
like [ __ ] gore everywhere and he's
just like okay well take care of that
like he's delivery's awesome music come
on help me this is the freshest body we
have you know know the other guys we can
bring him back to life yeah because
otherwise if you don't you're gonna be
in big trouble
you know nothing ever works out right
but you know you have to admire dr. Wes
optimism he just thinks the next
breakthrough he's like all I have to do
is I just need fresher and fresher
corpses and then one day we're gonna
figure this [ __ ] out
yeah and it's a series though it does
evolve he realizes there's more more
than you you need to do more and more to
bring somebody back to life for real
make him normal yeah yeah which you find
in later movies that comes into play
there was actually supposed to because
like I said we did a review
beyond reanimate er which was the third
one there was actually rumors floating
around that there was supposed to be
eventually I don't know if they're gonna
do it now they probably won't but they
were gonna do a fourth one that was
gonna be called island of reanimate er
that was gonna have the same like island
of doctor Moreau vibe to it which is
actually a great idea why didn't they do
it and I kind of wish they well I don't
know they've been talking about it for
years and years and I don't know if
they're ever up there ever gonna do that
would be a hit yeah I mean everyone's
they're all still alive pretty much I
mean you know Jeff Holmes is still
kicking
he's awesome he got better as he got
older I loved him on our Trek stuff that
he did did commander Shran on emperor on
enterprise one of the best yeah the
Andorian Couric commander and he was
like that was one of the best characters
from enterprise and Sid was the oh man
Enterprise suck Enterprise got good
after a couple of seasons it did have
one of the best mirror episodes and
two-part myrups that ever of all times
we are dark moon no end of it yeah you
are
bi Mia Jeffrey Combs is right up there
with Bruce Campbell as far as I'm
concerned yeah I mean those two
basically like how can you not love
those two guys you see school like I
said if you don't then I can't be
friends with you and you know and then
the guy who did phantasm yeah similar
yeah like I said if you're gonna make a
horror movie like this yeah you just
[ __ ] go for broke man use 24 gallons
of blood like they did on the show it's
just like cut people's heads off just to
cut people's arms off do all kind of
[ __ ] it's just crazy it's fun and you
know like I said how can you not love
reanimate her you got a library animator
all right so I guess that'll do it our
little kitty is like yeah I'm like going
she's like get on the show
look at little baby cookie bite you when
I bite her
she loves to wrestle yeah she's a tomboy
she thinks she's she thinks she thinks
she's a gummy bear actually she does
this a lot yeah you why do you being a
gummy bear oh look she's just totally
relaxed yeah and she does this on the
floor lays on her back she is a total
daddy's girl yeah yeah yeah she loves
her daddy yeah she won't know how I
became father to a cat oh you're good at
it though she loves you
she comes in and like wants to wrestle
all the time yeah walk away from when
she grabs me on the back of the heel
she's rolling around rolling a carpet
not roll or go to play across the room
yeah that sound like do it again she's a
puppy or a tiny human yeah but yeah all
right so that'll wrap it up for our
breakdown of reanimate ur like I said if
you haven't seen it I don't know what's
the matter with you but go see it right
now it's on shudder we're gonna rent it
just do something go see it okay yeah
yeah actually if you don't subscribe to
shudder and you're a subscriber you're
kind of wrong it's only $5 a month and
I'm not plugging it we know they're not
giving us anything although they can if
they want to you call me shudder money
off shatters but no seriously that it's
a really good sir five bucks you get to
see all this cool books a month and they
add new stuff every time and you can
watch it over your xbox and I think you
can watch it / ps4 don't yeah last week
they added like I said they added a
bunch of the Halloween movies they added
a [ __ ] ton of Alfred Hitchcock movies
like all his classic ones like the birds
and they have in Psych original shorts
that they made one of them was almost
x-rated I my name was showing a girl's
couch and a big I came out of it it was
weird man it's all fun and games till an
eye comes out of your cage I didn't like
the rest of the show but that was quite
an indelible image I have to say oh
that's right yeah yeah we see I was
supposed to be Lovecraft man but it
really kind of wasn't yeah it was just
kind of like a softcore porn your and I
don't think they really understood
Lovecraftian horror it wasn't really
filmed in that they tried to do it but
it was a short I think it was only 15
minutes or something like that it was 20
minute dim hat it didn't have the right
tone but yeah but yeah and like I said
if you know I'm shudder like I said it's
only $5 month they got documentaries and
[ __ ] they got short films they got a V
series I haven't even looked into that
yet yes I'm still watching all the movie
it's worth getting that an AMC Stubbs
has been worth they can give us money to
if they want yeah we're just plugging
them for free we just like it oh um we
have to fit we're having a problems with
this with our shirts
they're not our shirts are not showing
up for sale on there yeah I mean they're
on there I've been trying to fix it it's
like we don't know dazzl has a weird
thing with like visibility like I'm
trying to like add them to a collection
and then you know I mean I'm like it
says they're visible yeah and yet some
people are telling I go there they don't
see him but then some people have told
me that they did see them so I don't
know if it's just I don't know I don't
know if it's maybe it's some browsers or
copyrights I don't know maybe you can
take you down and put it back up there
or something I don't know I don't know
figure something out
and we fixed it so the new book you can
easily see it now on
yeah it's now now it's associated on my
author page to get to do it yeah well
you have to add it to your library right
on your author central I forgot to do
that but yeah so remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media and share with all
your friends and remember if you'd like
to financially support the show you can
go to our patreon page at patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give us a one-time donation if you
would like to and remember our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday and our
movie reviews come out every Friday and
we will see you next time bye